Today, I show you the last nine trades
that I took using my system in the last
two weeks, which are in my opinion the
most brutal weeks of 2026 so far. And
for the new viewers who are not familiar
with my system that brings me numbers
like this on my personal account and
like this on prop firms, I will leave
the full strategy breakdown in the
description down below. And now, let's
jump into charts. Let's start with
Monday, the 8th of June. As you can see
here at market open, price is under all
the EMAs, and they are all pointing
down. So, my bias was bearish for that
day. Plus, many people asked me why I
didn't take this pre-market FVG
inversion, simply because I never take
pre-market FVGs on Monday. That's why I
waited for a bullish FVG to be printed
inside the session. We have one right
here. And one other thing before I
forget, yes, I switched the bias right
here when we got over the one-hour EMA,
but we didn't have any entry trigger.
Then, when price got back under the
one-hour EMA and inverse this bullish
FVG that we have here, I entered after
this candle close, placed my stop loss
over the inversion candle, the FVG, and
over also the one-hour EMA. So, we have
three layers of protection for this
trade. I was targeting this previous
liquidity, but I closed my trade right
here, right before market closure, and I
made 2.2 Rs, as you can see right here
on the 8th, almost 7K. Now, let's go to
the next day.
Right at market open in this candle, my
bias was bullish for that day because we
were over all the EMAs, and they were
pointing up. Then, the sell-off started.
We broke all the three EMAs with the big
fat red candle, which indicates strong
momentum that inverse three pre-market
FVGs all at once. I took the risk,
entered right here after candle closure,
placed my stop loss over all the three
FVGs and the 30-minute EMA. I was going
to target this previous liquidity that
you see right here, but to be honest
with you, I chickened out and targeted
2R because I didn't think that the price
will move 700 points. This day was
Tuesday, the 9th of June. As you can see
here, a little bit over 6K. Now, let's
go to the next day. For this day, it's
clearly that the EMAs are pointing down.
Price opened under all of them. That
means my bias was bearish for that day.
I waited for a bullish FVG to be printed
in this pullback. It didn't happen. We
inverse this pre-market FVG with this
candle. I entered, placed my stop loss
over the FVG, over the inversion candle,
and this previous candle. So, we have
again three layers of protection. Was
going after 2R, but I closed my trade
right here before market closure and
ended up making a little bit over 1R.
And for the people who keep asking me
whether they take a pre-market FVG or a
session FVG, this is purely your choice
to make. Let's take this day as an
example. You've seen that I took a
pre-market FVG, but if we zoom in and
for example, you don't want to take a
pre-market FVG, you can see that we have
a bullish FVG right here. We go in in a
short position. We place our stop loss
over the FVG, over the inversion candle,
and over the 15-minute EMA. So, we have
three layers of protection and you will
be closing your trade right here when
market closes. You'll be making a little
bit under 1R. So, there is no hard rule
whether you take a pre-market FVG or a
session FVG. Like I said in multiple
occasions, pre-market FVGs will be
always a lower probability trade, but I
use them when I believe that we can have
a directional day. So, if you want to
focus 100% on sessions FVG, no problem
about that. Like I told you, this is
your choice to make. I hope that I
replied to your questions about the
pre-market FVG or the session FVG and
also about the stop loss placement. And
if you still have questions, make sure
to drop them in the comment section down
below. And let's continue the video. I
will be dropping more golden nuggets.
This day was Wednesday, the 10th of
June, a little bit over 3K. Let's jump
to the next one.
Market opened and we were under all the
three EMAs and they were pointing down.
My bias was bearish for that day. Plus,
we don't have any pre-market FVG in this
pullback. I waited for a bullish FVG to
be formed, as you can see right here.
Then, we inversed it with this candle. I
entered, made a mistake and placed my
stop loss over the inversion candle and
the FVG. So, I had that day only two
layers of protection. I will say it out
loud, I made a mistake. My stop loss
needs to be here, over the EMA, three
layers of protection, but I will be
stopped out too with this wick. This was
a textbook setup and it was a
statistical loss. This was Thursday, the
11th of June. I lost a little bit over
3K. So, since the 8th of June, I started
to risk 3K per trade instead of 2K
previously. So, this P&L that you see
right here was all done by risking 2K
per trade. And if we get back right
here, even if we placed our stop loss
over the previous candle or even over
the recent swing high, we will be
stopped out, no matter what. Some days
we'll be stopped out, no matter what we
do. And for the ones who will say that
the EMAs were flat right here, like I
told you previously, we need to count
the EMAs from the beginning of the Asian
session. As you can see, we have an
angle right here on the 1-hour EMA.
That's why my bias was bearish for that
day. Now, let's jump to the next one.
Market opened over all the EMAs. They
are pointing up, as you can see here
from the start of the Asian session. We
have many bearish FVGs in this pullback.
Price inversed them with this candle. I
entered, placed my stop-loss under the
white EMA, and this was also a mistake
from me because the stop-loss needs to
be under the 1-hour EMA, under the
inversion candle, and under the FVGs.
But, as you can see, even if I used
three layers of protection, I would be
stopped out, too. But, here in this
straight, I admit it, I made a mistake
of placing my stop-loss right here. The
stop-loss needs to be at this level. And
for any reason that I decide to take a
trade based on session FVG, not this
pre-market weak one, you can see clearly
that we have a bearish FVG. We will
enter after this inversion. We will
place our stop-loss under the FVG, under
the inversion candle, and under the
30-minute EMA. But, we will be out
basically at break even. You'd be
closing your trade at this candle right
before market closer. This was Friday,
the 12th of June. As you can see, a
little bit over 3K loss. Now, let's jump
to the next one.
Don't forget to subscribe, like, and
drop your comments down below, and tell
me what do you think about the new look
of using the glasses because I get
blinded by the light above me. So, for
this day, as you can see, we are clearly
bullish. Price opened over all the EMAs.
They are pointing up and like you know,
on Mondays we don't take premarket FVG.
We can clearly see that we have a small
FVG right here between these three
candles. This is a bearish FVG. You
always need to zoom in if you need to
spot this kind of FVG's. For premarket
FVG's, the size matters, but for session
FVG's, I don't care about the size. We
have an inversion of this FVG. I
entered, placed my stop loss under the
FVG, under the inversion candle, and
under the previous candle. So, like
always, three layers of protection and I
targeted two hours. This was Monday the
15th of June, 6K here on the dashboard.
Now, let's check the next trade.
We were clearly bullish from the start
of the Asian session. My bias was
bullish for that day. Price is over the
EMAs, especially one hour one. I have
this premarket FVG right at the bottom
of this pullback. Not like some days we
have premarket FVG's right here. I don't
take them at all. I trade pullbacks with
this strategy and the lower a premarket
FVG is better for a buy position and the
higher a premarket FVG is the better for
a sell position. I entered, placed my
stop loss under the inversion candle,
the FVG, and the previous candle. So,
like always, three layers of protection
and I was immediately stopped out with
this candle. And also for this day, no
matter what you do, you will be stopped
out whether you take a premarket FVG or
a session FVG. No matter what, you will
be stopped out. This was the Tuesday
16th of June. I lost a little bit under
3K. And now to the next day.
We were clearly bearish for this day. As
you can see here from the start of the
Asian session, we are clearly bearish.
Price opened under all the EMAs. Let me
tell you why I didn't take pre-market
FVG's that we have here in this
pullback. As you can see here, these
pre-market FVG's are too small. That's
why I told you previously, I take
pre-market FVG size in consideration.
That's why I didn't enter. Also, there
are many of you who asked me why I
didn't switch the bias when we had this
bullish candle right here. Plus, we have
an inversion of this bearish candle.
Guys, tell me, where do you see that the
price broke all the EMAs with momentum?
I personally don't see it here in this
candle. It's the complete opposite. We
rejected the EMAs with this candle.
Yeah, we have a break of all the EMAs
with the momentum at this candle, but
where is the entry trigger? Where is the
FVG that this candle inverse? If we look
to the left, this candle right here
inverse no FVG. That's why, yes, I
switched the bias, but we didn't have
any entry trigger. Now, let's get back
to my trade. You can clearly see that we
have a bullish FVG, and we broke it with
this red candle. I entered, placed my
stop loss over the FVG, the inversion
candle, and over the white EMA. So, I
have three layers of protection, and I
hope that the stop loss placement is
clear for you right now because I keep
saying three layers of protection over
and over again. So, the stop loss
placement will no longer be a problem
for you. And if you need help to make
the strategy works, and to have me on
your shoulder every single day watching
your trades, correcting your mistakes,
giving you a road map to be six or even
seven figures funded, and to have
results like my students here on the
screen, click on the mentorship link
down below, apply, and book a call with
me to see if you are the right fit. And
now, let's go back to the video. Like I
said, I entered here, I targeted two
hours, and this day was Wednesday, the
17th of June. I made a little bit over
6K. Now, to the next day.
We are clearly bullish for this day.
Price is making higher highs and higher
low. Price opened above all the EMAs and
rejected all three of them. Then, we
formed a bearish FVG after market open.
I entered at this green candle, placed
my stop loss right below the FVG, the
inversion candle, and made a mistake
again with my stop loss placement. My
stop loss needs to be right here, at the
previous candle, so I can have three
layers of protection. One, the inversion
candle. Two, the FVG. And three, the
previous candle. But, for this day, like
I told you, I made the mistake and ended
up losing. I promise you, I will never
repeat this stop loss mistakes ever
again. This day was Thursday, the 18th
of June. I lost a little bit over 3K.
This is the only trade in the nine trade
that I showed you that I could have
avoided the stop loss. If I placed my
stop loss correctly, I would be out from
this trade right at this level at 1.67R.
Make sure to subscribe, like, tell me in
the comments down below what do you want
to see on my next videos, and let's meet
on the next one.